now we're going to set up our
development environment to get ready
you're going to need to install some
things if you don't already have them
installed the first thing you're going
to need is Java and you're going to need
the jdk 1.7 also known as Java 7 you
probably already have it on your
computer but if you don't you're going
to need to download that now and then
the next thing you're going to need is
Apache maven and then you're also going
to want to use Eclipse you don't have to
use Eclipse when you're using maven
projects but we strongly recommend it
and during this course all the
instructions are going to assume that
you are using Eclipse also recommend
that you get Eclipse EE because it comes
with built-in support for maven
if you already have standard Eclipse
installed you can add the maven m2e
plug-in to it but really I think you're
going to have a much better experience
if you just use Eclipse EE some of the
things in the maven plugin for Eclipse
don't quite work right now one thing you
don't have to install is the App Engine
SDK and this is because when you have
maven projects you specify all the
dependencies in a configuration file
called pom dot XML and it's in this pom
dot XML where you're going to specify
the version of App Engine SDK that you
want and then maven will just download
the App Engine SDK for you so if you
need help installing any of these
components we've written a document for
you to help guide you through installing
them and you can find a link to that
document in the instructor notes for
this lesson so go ahead and install each
of these and when you've done it go
ahead and check the box here so that we
know you're ready to continue